[Music]
on this tuesday night the potential cost
of covid19 new action to stop the virus
from infecting the economy
and from spreading to more people it's
not just our usual influenza season
plus keeping it clean your best defense
to stay healthy released on bail new
details on those canadians detained in
ethiopia
the democratic presidential race becomes
a race to stop
bernie sanders i don't think we should
have a socialist heading up our ticket
more contenders back out to back joe
biden on this super tuesday
and an appalling trend the recent rise
of racism
against indigenous canadians
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the fast evolving
developments of the kovid 19 outbreak
action is now being taken to try to
limit the impact on the global economy
the u.s central bank slashed its
benchmark interest rate by half a
percentage point today the biggest
one-time rate cut since the 2008
financial crisis
that didn't do anything to calm the
markets though the dow jones closed
down almost 800 points and there's a new
warning the virus could cut
global economic growth in half today
finance ministers and central bankers
from the world's advanced economies
including canada
held an emergency conference call to
coordinate a response
prime minister justin trudeau is
reassuring canadians
we recognize the very real economic
impacts of
the coronavirus globally we also
recognize that there will be impacts on
canadian businesses on canadian
entrepreneurs and we will always look
for ways to
minimize that impact and perhaps give
help where help is needed
there are six new confirmed cases in
canada today the total is now 33
all of them are in ontario nbc except
for one in quebec and all are connected
to travel from other countries the
global number of confirmed cases has now
surpassed 92
000 more than 3 100 people have died
the world health organization says that
puts the world in uncharted territory
it says the mortality rate from this
virus appears to be more than three
percent
and that's much higher than seasonal flu
which kills far fewer
than one percent of people affected in
tonight's top story michaela couture
looks at preparations underway
here in canada for a potential spread
it's the next stage in the fight against
covid 19.
toronto area transit agencies have
started disinfecting buses and trains
daily
to stop any spread of the novel
coronavirus
we piloted a special
long-acting anti-microbial agent
on a train it was quite successful it's
an additional measure at a time when the
federal health minister continues to say
the current response is working federal
government works very closely with
provincial and territorial partners
on all kinds of different technical
governing bodies that help
make sure that where our systems are
ready should we see an outbreak in any
community
they say they're ready but they've yet
to lay out a battle plan for a possible
outbreak in the way other countries have
so what's canada's plan the basic plan
that i understand is the pandemic
influenza plan that will be adapted
nationwide to deal with this dr st john
helped to develop the influenza plan
after the sars outbreak in 2003
he says it's not time to implement it
but it is time to explain it to
canadians
i think it would give people a sense
that
there is number one there is a plan
number two
that has it is a multiple component plan
it deals with the private sector it
deals with security sectors like police
fire
ambulance he says public health
officials are trying to strike the
delicate balance between informing the
public
and causing panic so far all of canada's
covid19 cases are travel related not
spread
within communities and that's why some
don't think
the federal or provincial governments
need to take possible next steps
each province has health protection
legislation that
enables medical officers of health to
put a person into quarantine if they
suspect that they may be developing a
disease
it's an extreme power that could be used
to fight a virus
which is spreading extremely quickly
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
across the border from british columbia
authorities are scrambling to get a grip
on a fast-moving outbreak in washington
state
as of tonight that state has confirmed
27 cases and nine deaths
it's the worst outbreak in the u.s and
many of the cases are linked to a
nursing home near seattle
of the three new deaths confirmed today
and authorities say
two were residents at that home one of
them a man in his 50s was in the
hospital when he died nearly a week ago
health care workers were apparently
unaware he had kovid 19 and authorities
are now investigating
whether any of them were exposed the u.k
which has 51
confirmed cases now is making clear it
expects the outbreak to get
significantly worse
and today the british prime minister
released a battle plan including
sweeping powers to deal with an
emergency while the vast majority of
people who become ill will get better
the uk expects the health system to be
stretched and up to one fifth of
employees could be off work at the same
time
crystal commansing is in london tonight
crystal
donna this is it 28 pages detailing
how the uk government will protect
people from the new coronavirus
if the situation escalates it outlines
everything from how many people could be
infected
to how the military will be used to
support local authorities
battle plans in hand the british prime
minister unveiled what people in the uk
could face during the ongoing epidemic
the plan
has four containing the virus
delaying its spread researching its
origins and cure
and finally mitigating the impact
the urgency to deliver something
tangible in the fight against kovid 19
ramped up following the first death of a
british citizen
last week he had been on the diamond
princess
cruise ship and now everyone is being
urged to think about
how they will cope if one in five people
develops the disease a worst case
scenario
i get the feeling i think the virus is
everywhere to be honest
and i think it's just affecting
different people in different ways
hasselmere southwest of london is just
one community where a person tested
positive
a pub had to be closed and disinfected
health officials are wondering how care
will be provided to
dozens of critically ill people co-fit
19 can cause
serious lung issues and the world health
organization warns even
advanced health care systems may be
taxed
it will be very important for everybody
to think not only what we can do
to prevent the spread of the virus
individually but also
what we can do to avoid too much
pressure on
the nhs right across the uk people are
being told if they think they're
infected to call the national health
service helpline or
if they're here in london to visit one
of the drive-through test locations
the government has outlined an action
plan that will be put in place with more
details to come
if this virus outbreak escalates donna
crystal gomencing in london thanks in
japan where nearly 300 cases of the
virus have been confirmed
the possibility was raised today about
postponing the olympic summer games in
tokyo
japan's olympic minister suggested the
games could be postponed until the end
of the year
the ioc though says it is committed to
kicking them off as planned
on july 24th and that athletes should
keep training
in iran the viruses hit upper levels of
government hard it appears the entire
leadership of that country may have been
exposed
the outbreak in iran is the deadliest
outside china more than 23 000
cases have been confirmed there 77
people have died
and 23 mps about 8 percent of parliament
are now said to be infected
two high-ranking officials including a
top adviser to the supreme leader
have died
ayatollah khamenei appeared in public
today wearing disposable gloves and he
hit back at allegations iran has
downplayed the outbreak
it's been handled with honesty and
transparency he says and
though the severity of it shouldn't be
overblown he did give the go-ahead to
mobilize three hundred thousand soldiers
and volunteers
the best way to protect yourself is the
simplest way wash your hands thoroughly
with soap and water that hasn't stopped
people from snapping up hand sanitizer
though it's becoming hard to find
we'll have more on that a little bit
later right now we have a developing
news story out of ethiopia where a group
of canadians were detained
last week they've now been granted bail
they are volunteers with an
alberta-based charity called canadian
humanitarian
liam nixon from global lethbridge broke
this story
and joins me now liam donna canadian
humanitarian confirms
bail has been posted for the 10
volunteers and three staff
charged with practicing medicine without
permission and dispensing expired
medication
the ngo is hopeful the group will be
released tomorrow
however it's still unknown when they'll
actually be allowed to return to canada
in a statement issued to global news
james murphy whose brother-in-law is
detained
says quote this has been deeply
distressing for all of us
and we are focusing all of our efforts
on getting our loved ones
back to canada safely and quickly ndp
international development critic heather
mcpherson traveled to ethiopia with the
ngo in 2012.
she confirms founders dr richard
northcott and deborah northcott are
among the detainees
along with others from alberta and bc
she says deborah was the team leader of
her 2012 trip
and is a close personal friend she is an
incredible woman very caring
very genuine very interested in the
well-being of people
around the world canadian humanitarian
spokesperson justin steed
says an ngo representative and consular
officers have been allowed access to the
prison
and can confirm the detainees are being
treated fairly and humanely
but ethiopian authorities are suggesting
they won't be allowed to leave the
country
until the investigation is complete
donna all right liam nixon in lethbridge
alberta thank you
canadians are among those hunkered down
as a powerful tornado ripped across
tennessee early this morning
at least 25 people are dead and the
damage is extensive a state of emergency
is in effect
in the heart of nashville the fierce
storm front shredded buildings tore
off roofs and buried people in piles of
debris
schools are closed tens of thousands of
people are without power
the storm hit fast and it left a trail
of destruction 16 kilometers long
canadian country music star brett kissel
lives in the nashville area and he said
it looks
like a war zone all of the giant green
signs were down
there was no lights anywhere the power
was out in that whole region
it was crazy to see a bunch of semis
were actually upside down
search teams are going door to door
looking for those who are still missing
president trump extended his condolences
to those affected and will visit the
area
friday we have some breaking news from
the united states polls are closing on
this super tuesday the biggest election
day on the democratic primary calendar
it will further narrow the field of
candidates likely to take on president
trump and right now
joe biden seems to be the one with
momentum the goal is to win the most
delegates
more than a third are up for grabs in 14
states and one u.s territory
california and texas are the day's
biggest prizes in total
1 357 delegates will be awarded a huge
chunk of the nearly 4 000 at stake the
results on super tuesday don't decide
everything but historically it has been
tough for a candidate to recover from a
poor performance
now abigail beeman is watching the
results come in
i voted for bernie bernie sanders heads
into super tuesday in the lead
we voted for vice president biden but
it's joe biden who got a remarkable
boost on super tuesday eve
let's take back this country with
endorsements from
three former rivals i'm delighted to
endorse and support
joe biden while i'm ending my campaign i
can't think of a better way to end it
than joining vice president biden did
joe biden promise you anything
no not at all amy klobuchar wouldn't say
whether she's interested in the vice
presidential ticket
in virginia voters we spoke to hope she
and pete buddha judge are rewarded
somehow i think they're great candidates
and it'll be a shame if we were to lose
them completely
i thought they were class act and we
hope that they get
a position in the new cabinet we know
that democratic leaders
are trying to make the case against
sanders and the other candidates seem to
be rallying to joe biden as the person
who can prevent
sanders from getting the nomination it's
not just the corporate establishment
that's getting nervous the political
establishment is getting nervous
are you worried about standards i am
indeed
i think he's just going to divide the
country and i think he would have a hard
time beating
trump in this environment i'm here today
because i believe in you meanwhile
elizabeth warren pushes to win in her
home state of massachusetts
where it's a fight with sanders and then
a wild card former new york mayor mike
bloomberg is on the ballot for the first
time
he's already spent more than 500 million
dollars on ads
dual canadian american citizen aj
bottish voted for him tuesday
i think the balance of politics
the he's not too extreme on either end
and i think he's going to be good for
the country he knows how to
run a company and he knows i think i
think he'll do well in terms of
the country as well
and donna as you mentioned we are
getting some early results from states
where polls have closed some of those
states it's too
early to call a winner but important to
note that joe biden is
showing some strength in the south he's
projected to win
in alabama in north carolina in virginia
as well and
no surprise that bernie sanders is
projected to win in his home
state of vermont but it could be a while
before we have the full results from
today's picture
the biggest state california 415
delegates it could take days
before we find out what happened there
donna all right abigail beeman
thanks an explosive situation in
indonesia coming up the volcano
triggering warnings on a densely
populated island
plus stupid human trick a stunt that
failed to impress the police
indonesia's mount merapi has erupted on
java island the most populated island in
the world
it shot a six kilometer high column of
smoke and ash into the sky
this is the most active of 500
indonesian volcanoes
the dust and ash forced the closure of a
busy nearby airport
people are being warned to stay three
kilometers away from the crater and that
rains could carry lava to nearby
communities
there's a big breakthrough in australia
for the first time in nearly eight
months there are no
active bushfires in the state of new
south wales
it has been overwhelmed by wildfires
since last july
the rural fire service tweeted today
that's more than 240 days of fire
activity for the state
record-breaking temperatures and months
of severe drought fueled the fires
across australia
at least 30 people died including a
number of firefighters
more than 3 000 homes were destroyed and
more than 11 million hectares of brush
and forest was burned
and an estimated 1 billion animals were
lost
recent cooler weather and rain helped
crews get those fires under control but
residents are being warned
hot dry weather could drive up the
danger again
ahead store shelves are short on hand
sanitizers
could a homemade recipe beat kovid 19.
okay so this is not a stunt obviously
anyone should try and it's landed a nova
scotia driver in hot water
the man behind the wheel turned himself
into the police today
he's facing mischief and other charges
the 39 year old did get out of that
sinking vehicle safely to the cheers of
onlookers but
mounties certainly weren't impressed
they say the stunt tied up rcmp
resources
including a dive team who put their own
lives at risk to make sure no one else
was in the water the risk we all keep
hearing about
right now is from the coronavirus and
the best way to protect yourself we're
told is to wash your hands and not touch
your face
but if you're not near a sink hand
sanitizer will do
and it seems people are paying attention
stores are running out
as ross lord reports people are even
trying to make their own
at home in halifax the squeeze is on
more people are using disinfectants to
keep the new coronavirus at bay
as a result drug store shelves are
either low on supplies
or completely sold out new mother teresa
bombardier
is adding a layer of protection against
covet 19.
i just walked out of there and i bought
wet ones the wipes the antibacterial
wipes for your hands
he's a year and a half almost and yeah i
i'm you know you want to be extra
careful with little ones and
comp people with compromised immune
systems stores that do have hand
sanitizer in stock are running out
fast at this store there were 200
containers to start the day
by noon all but a handful were sold
yep i did buy more went and got big
thing at costco of the lysol wipes
with liquid disinfectants becoming
scarce homemade solutions are being
promoted online
like this one mixing an alcohol compound
with aloe vera
this has turned into a gel-like
substance
this infection control manager in nova
scotia is confident mainstream
sanitizers will kill the new strain of
coronavirus
but she's reluctant to endorse
do-it-yourself methods
as long as it has that higher alcohol
content it's fine but i'm not
an expert or know about these home
remedies it's not something we certainly
do in health care
if sanitizers aren't available good old
soap and water provides protection too
you try to get up to 20 seconds we tell
you sing happy birthday to yourself
that's
one good tip there are other new tips
with each passing day
including the nba discouraging players
from high fiving with fans
but officials in canada continue to
preach good overall hygiene
and common sense as the best solution
ross lord
global news halifax
up next the racist reactions to the rail
blockades and who is hurting the most
concern for me
all the attention that's been paid to
the hereditary chiefs in northern bc
and the rail blockades that have
happened in support of them has elevated
the discussion about indigenous rights
and title
many people think it's about time it has
raised awareness
but it's also led to a backlash tonight
heather yurix west looks at the surge in
racism
indigenous canadians are enduring some
of my earliest memories
leaving the reserve has been
are to do with racism and being treated
differently
gabrielle lindstrom says every
indigenous canadian has come to
experience racism
many times in their lives but the last
few weeks have been
particularly difficult as the recent
protests give those with racist beliefs
a feeling
of justification sort of adds
adds fuel to to a fire that's been
burning
for hundreds of years on friday the
tension came to a head in this central
alberta town
the high school was locked down after
videos containing racial slurs began
circulating online those monitoring
social media channels say
online racism towards indigenous people
has become
rampant a lot of comments were like
inciting violence um
you know people had open profiles you
know they didn't seem to be worried
about sort of like you know what they
were saying and who was looking at it
so yeah it was it was pretty awful on
globalnews.ca
and its facebook pages social media
journalists have had to delete hundreds
of racist comments since the blockades
began
canada's anti-hate network which
monitors the activity of far-right and
extremist groups
has also seen an increase in posts
targeting indigenous activists
it's a lot on facebook a lot on twitter
it's been escalating
since it began but it's not just online
this indigenous hockey player says she
was called a racial slur during a recent
game in calgary
for gabrielle lindstrom it's a reminder
that even in a time of reconciliation
racist views against indigenous
canadians are still widely held
and it hurts it's the lack of of
of of action on the part of of society
to to speak up against
what is essentially violence to speak up
against it and
and i think that's what hurts the most
is
it's it's just people watching heather
urex west global news
calgary and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is jasper alberta
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
[Music]
you